hello everyone and welcome to a very
important game from round seven of the
usgs championship it's fabiana carwana
versus ray robson and it's a very
important game for many reasons uh for
fobby it's because he already lost two
games so he took a real beating on his
classical rating but also on his chances
to actually contend for the first prize
in the usgs championship and
for ray robson uh who so far has not
lost a single game he's doing excellent
and a draw or win against fabio would
definitely propel him towards uh winning
winning the whole thing so let's see uh
what happened here as the game is uh
quite a lot to take in uh so fabi with
the white pieces opens with c4 he goes
for the english opening with e5 by
robson knight to c3 knight to f6 and now
g3 going for the carl's bremen system
and now bishop to b4 attacking the
knight here this missile of um uh
variation we have e4 we had this
position quite a lot lately so of course
you guys already know that grabbing this
pawn doesn't really do anything so black
just continues development knight to c6
bishop to g2 and d6 now uh we have h3 h3
is very rare here usually in just knight
g to e2 is played but here h3 very rare
from fabi yeah bishop to e6 continuing
development putting pressure on this
pawn and d3 nicely defending this spawn
and now castles here is a known move but
uh robson goes for knight to d7 and it
is already as of move seven that we have
a completely new game so he's saying to
fabi i'm ready to play f5 uh open up the
position and it's gonna be um uh
it's gonna be a crazy game uh fabi says
all right let's see it he plays knight
to e2 prepares the castle at the safety
and now f5 so what do you do here well
fab just castles he doesn't mind uh
black capturing or pushing the pawn
doesn't really do anything uh for
example if we we could even sacrifice a
pawn here to kind of open up the white
king but we don't have any anything to
attack the white king with and it's uh
it's a very important pawn that we've
just uh thrown away basically because we
don't want to allow f5 uh f5 we don't
want to capture here and allow knight
captures on f4 then the bishop will be
hanging so maybe not the the greatest of
ideas so here uh robson just castles and
fabi now pushes f4 himself
we have bishop captures on c3 now this
bishop is no longer very useful the king
is not on e1 so it's not even pinning
the knight and all of our pawns are in
dark squares so here bishop captures on
c3 we have knight captures on c3 and now
f captures an e4 and it's always a
question whether to capture or not maybe
you could improve the position with
knight to c5 put some pressure on blacks
and whites position uh but okay here we
have f captures on e4 knight captures an
e4 now fabi improved the position of his
knight and the h6 taking away the g5
square from the white knight we have g4
by fabi now maybe getting ready to push
this pawn all the way to f5
and orozo now trades on f4 we have pawn
captures bishop captures and now d5 and
here black can be very happy he got rid
of everything he almost completely
developed and he
has a very very enjoyable position the
white king is uh
somewhat open so we'll see what happens
however you do not want to trade down
too much because white still has the
bishop pair so c captures bishop
captures and now queen to d2 connecting
the rooks developing the queen knight to
d4 and now rook 8 to e1 and fabi's
pieces are now fully mobilized we have
knight to e6 going after this bishop and
of course fabi saves it bishop the g3
now it's a question whether black should
consider c6 right away as you do not
want this c7 pawn to remain a target
forever
but first he goes for rook captures on
f1 check rook captures and now knight d
the c5 uh putting more pressure on the
knight here
and here you could uh consider something
like knight captures knight captures and
rook to f5 you could force some trades
this way for example bishop captures
king captures or rather even queen
captures and you'd get this position and
it seems that the white uh is not to be
preferred here because you have uh well
such a loose king and the queens are
still on the board uh but it's actually
uh a very enjoyable position for white
you're attacking um a lot you're putting
a lot of pressure on the queen side here
and your rook is already developed
unlike black's rook that's not developed
and the d3 pawn is of course off limits
if you capture it just rook d5 hangs the
knight and if you try something like
queen captures of course this hangs the
knight here uh for example queen
captures on d3 rook captures on c5 and
it seems like you can win the rook back
for example queen d4 check but bishop f2
saves our rook so
it's a very tricky position whether you
should go for it or not fabi decides to
go for for queen to c3 it ensures more
trades and trades are what he's looking
for uh so knight captures on e4 d
captures on e4 now fabi gets a beautiful
pass pawn here uh bishop to c6 and now
queen to b3 pinning the knight and uh
what do you do here uh will you have to
defend it but first queen to d4 check
king to h2 yeah and now rook to e8 of
course this is how we will defend we
want to activate our rook as well and
then later on we're going to unpin so
our knight can move so rook to d1 fabby
chases the queen away and now what do
you do with the queen you could keep the
queens on the board with something like
queen to c5 or you could go for a queen
trade queen a4 queen the b6 also offers
a queen trade but you should definitely
do something because that c7 pawn is
hanging the knight here is pinned the
knight cannot move so here queen to a4
uh trading the queens ensures the
unpinning over knight on e6 and uh this
is uh what robson goes for so queen
captures bishop captures on a4 and now
rook to d5 this is a fine move by fabi
this rook to d5 idea
as it ensures the knight
the knight stays on this square the
problem is if you go for something let
that
activate it right away there's no square
for it for example knight to g5 is a
nice square but uh we're gonna capture
on c7 so you haven't really accomplished
anything here if you capture on e4 uh we
don't mind uh i mean okay the material
is equal we can play rook to a5 go after
the bishop go after this pawn so
maybe not not the way to go so instead
bishop the c6 attacking the rook rook to
e5 now fabi would very much enjoy
trading rooks here then he would have
the bishop pair against the bishop and
knight and it it is definitely favorable
since the game is on both sides of the
board so g5 here uh and bishop to f1 now
trying to shift the bishop over to uh to
this c4 square as the king is still on
this diagonal soaking to g7 unpinning
and now king to g2 both players starting
the activation of their kings
king to f6 and now king to f2 so looks
looks a bit scary but the king is
perfectly fine there
and now you could consider a move like
rook to d8 as now the king is defending
the knight maybe you can activate and
then maybe you can try something but
okay king e3 prevents rook d2 the game
continues but the rook remains in the
game however robson decides that uh the
the trading of the rooks is uh well
either favorable or you know
insignificant
uh so he decides to go for knight to f4
and fabi very happily trades the rook so
rook captures bishop captures and now
king to e3 and now we have this end game
where uh the bishop pair is fighting
against the bishop and knight with both
kings very active king to e5 uh robson's
king is a little bit more active
occupying d5 square whereas fabi's king
is on the e3 square and now bishop to e1
we're gonna kick away this king very
easily so we don't have to worry about
that king being overly active so knight
back to e6 bishop to c for now uh we
have bishop to g6 putting pressure on
the pawn here but the just b4 we don't
really care about this pawn because if
black captures it to bishop c3 check and
we win that bishop so after b4 we have
a6 and now we have a6 and now we have a4
uh knight to f4 now putting pressure on
the h3 pawn and now fabi's idea was
bishop to c3 check king to d6 and now
bishop to g7 going after this pawn and
now if you trade for example captures
captures uh then this knight is stuck
here guarding this um
uh g uh g5 pawn and it's not a great
square for the knight uh you know it's
uh
for example bishop to f1
could even get trapped there okay you
have the f4 square but you're going to
lose the g5 pawn so not not the greatest
and white can even shift this bishop
over to f6 to still put pressure on this
pawn while controlling these two squares
the bishop covers e6 so the bishop
square will really restrict the
movements of the black king so instead
after bishop to g7 we have h5 uh trying
to trade off this way but now bishop
back to f1 fabi defends the h3 pawn
captures captures and now knight back to
e6 uh we have bishop to f6 as we said
the bishop is nicely controlling these
squares not allowing the king to go
anywhere and we're still putting
pressure on g5 so the knight can't
really move so king d7 uh a5 now it
makes sense to put our pawns on dark
squares since uh robson has a light
square bishop uh we have king back to d6
bishop to c for now and king to d7 we
have bishop to d5 putting pressure on
the pawn here and now uh what do you do
you could uh try to
move the knight and defend it like this
but that doesn't really work since the
bishop covers that square and you really
like your knight here it prevents the
king from going anywhere deeper into the
position so just c6
bishop back to c4 and now bishop to h7
black really has nothing to do here
other than wait and see what fabi does
so bishop to d4
you don't really want to capture this
because like we said the knight here is
an excellent piece just regarding the
king
preventing the white king from reaching
deeper into the position so bishop g6
and now bishop to f6 we have bishop to
h7 and now bishop to f1
you could eliminate the knight yes you
do win the d4 square for for your king
for example you could even win the pawn
but now it's bishops of opposite colors
and uh well it doesn't matter if you're
up upon this will be an easy draw for
black since
uh in bishops of opposite colors uh
it's uh it's possible to draw even when
you're down material so bishop h7 we
have bishop back to f1 and now king the
e8 so robson is saying okay do we do we
draw this or what do you want to do but
fabi already
lost the two of the previous games and
this is classical time format he has
nothing to lose he's he lose here he can
only win uh so of course he's going to
keep pushing bishop d3 bishop g6 bishop
to c4 knocking to d7 uh black has an
other idea uh it's the either wait for
the for the 50 move rule or to get some
sort of a three-fold repetition so
bishop to d4 now asking do you want to
trade of course not bishop back to h7 we
have bishop to a7 uh now bishop to g6
fabi trying all of all of the squares
bishop to b3 king e7 bishop to c2 and
now king to d7 uh we have king f3 bishop
to h7 bishop back to e3 and now bishop
to g6 and now bishop to d3 uh we have
king to a7 king to e2 king to e8 and now
king to d2 we have king to f8 now comes
the bishop to c5 check
and
do you capture the bishop now well it's
a very interesting position for example
if you capture the bishop now then b
captures on c5
yes you want all of these dark squares
for your for your king but the problem
is this position is a dead draw and it
seems like uh fabi uh unknowingly
offered the draw by playing this uh
offer of a bishop but maybe robson
decided against it maybe it's hard to
imagine that robson wanted more than a
draw from this position
maybe he just trusted fabi that fabi
could win this position because after
captures captures
uh notice how uh there is no square for
the white king to go deeper into the
position all of these squares are
covered so you only have to worry about
the e5 square and that's easily taken
care of for example king e7 king c3
we're gonna play bishop to f7 and we
don't even care king d4 we're gonna play
anything bishop to a2 if king e5 we're
just going to go back bishop to e6 and
there's no way for the black for the
white king to go anywhere you can't push
any pawns uh the light square bishop is
completely useless here there's nothing
you can do here this is a dead draw so
what happened here did fabi uh knowingly
offered this did you know they both just
miss it it's hard to say maybe some of
you could uh caught an interview after
the game maybe they talked about it a
little bit but okay king the g7 was
played he didn't grab the bishop and now
king to e3 now the king is already
closer and now
it could be a bit of a problem because
this is one very important tempo so king
g8 bishop the c for now again attacking
the knight uh end king sorry now bishop
to f7 we have bishop to e7 by fabi
grabbing more space here and now we have
king the g7 again uh we we can't really
make prog progress here by by capturing
anything because then bishop captures
also wins this pawn so e5 now a very
important pawn push and now king the g8
uh you of course know that um
if 50 moves are played without any
pieces or pawns being captured or
without pawns being moved it's a draw by
the 50 move rule so moving this pawn
was very important so king to d2 we have
came to g7 now bishop back to d3 still
trying to figure out a way into the
position uh because as long as this
knight is here we cannot uh
go anywhere so king back to g8 bishop to
f5 now and king to g7 uh we have king to
d3 knight to f4 check king to d4 and not
knight back to e6 with check king c4
and now king to g8 and here
again a very interesting position
where uh you could uh enter the position
but it's it's still not enough this is
uh the the problem of the end game see
it doesn't matter how much you work it's
still a draw
because if bishop captures bishop
captures and king c5 yes you are going
after those pawns but bishop captures ng
for king b6 we're gonna play king of
seven go after the bishop here bishop
captures and g5 king captures and be uh
sorry king to a6 king captures on b7 and
after let's say bishop to a2 defending
this pawn
now you can capture this pawn and lose
this pawn still a draw or you can defend
this pawn then we defend this pawn it's
still a draw equal material bishops of
opposite colors so instead after this
king to g8 move fabi found a different
idea he decided to sacrifice a piece
and now he played bishop captures on g5
so you save your bishop pair for 70
moves and then you sacrifice it
so let's see let's see his area and he's
also discover allowing this discovery so
knight captures on g5 opening up a
discovery here with chuck uh the only
move you can play king the c5 now comes
bishop to d5 uh we have bishop the c8
going after the pawn here and now is the
critical moment of the game the game is
uh objectively still a draw but uh
finding a move that draws for black
requires a lot of thought
so feel free to pause the video and try
to figure it out while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it uh congratulations on being a true
master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight the e6 with check no that's not
it that's what fabi played that's what
uh
uh robson played uh and it's uh
it's similar to the to the move that uh
doesn't lose but it
comes with one very important difference
the actual move is knight to e4 check
and this is how we get a draw the
crucial point here is that we take away
the d6 square from the white king
because now after king to b6 we have
this c5 move this allows us to draw we
also guard the the pawn here and after b
captures on c5 we play king f7 and now
after bishop captures on b7 we simply
trade captures captures knight captures
and c5 with check guarding this spawn
and now the point is after king to be e6
we play knight to d7 check and the thing
is the king is enough to stop both of
these pawns and the knight only has to
stop this pawn and that's very easily
done king captures an a6 we're gonna
play king to e6 now king b7 ready to
advance the past pawn but just king
captures on e5 because if you ever push
this pawn to a6 knight c5 check and the
knight captures the a6 pawn so of course
uh you're gonna go after the knight but
we just play knight c5 again we protect
the a6 square then king b6 or king c6
goes after the knight knight to a6
blocking the pawn now again we attack it
king to b6 knight to b8 again we're
ready to sacrifice our knight for the
pawn and if king to b7 just knight back
to d7 and again if you push a6 knight c5
check picks up the pawn so we did a full
circle but it's enough to draw the game
but in the game after bishop to c8
bishop knight to the e4 was not played
uh knight the e6 check was played and
this is much much different because now
fabi doesn't have to go to b6 fobby
plays king to d6 and this is just much
much stronger now c5 does nothing
because bishop captures an e6 comes with
check or even better
king captures and d5 threatening bishop
captures on e6 with check so you have to
play king f7 to guard material here but
now bishop captures on b7 we have bishop
to c4 guarding the a6 pawn bishop
captures on c6 and now knight to d4 so
okay maybe you can still fight your
upper piece but now bishop to d5 check
fabi gives up
his last bishop bishop captures king
captures and now knight to b5 so can the
knight stop all of these pawns uh very
unlikely we have g5 uh king the e7 now
comes g6 uh the pawns are now creating a
wall against the black king so you can't
really do all that much
we have knight to c3 check king to c6
now comes knight to eight you're going
after the spawn uh and fabio of course
advances it to b5 so a captures on b5
king captures on b5 knight to c3 check
now king c4 not allowing this knight to
cause any any problems here guarding
these squares and if not here you will
not have this square for your knight so
knights the a4 was played now king to b4
uh chasing away the knight again these
two squares are not available not back
to b2 and only now do we push our pawn
to a6 with knight to d3 check king to b5
and not knight to f4 but you don't
really care about those pawns just um uh
you can simply advance it uh but you
still have to be very careful for
example if you if you push this pawn g7
then uh the king can still reach it and
maybe some knight to d5 to here uh it
doesn't work but still you have to be
careful fabi still advances the pawn to
g7 we have king to f7 and now a7 so what
do you play here knight to d5 of course
the knight is a menace up until the very
last moment now if you bring a queen
into game of course knight c7 check
picks up the queen and it's still a draw
so here uh what you have to play is uh
we can even show it if you guys want
knight c7 check the king will go let's
say to b6 we're going to capture king b7
you can pick up this pawn captures and
now of course we are much much faster
than the white king we're going to pick
up this pawn as well so instead after
knight to d5 fabi played g8 check and he
brought a bishop into the game not a
queen because it serves the same purpose
and it's much much more stylish uh why
wouldn't we want that uh and he was in
this position on move 90 that ray robson
resigned the game and unfortunately uh
he is no longer
in the lead of the us chess championship
but fabi broke his losing streak i mean
it's incredibly rare for for a player
like fabi to lose two classical games in
a row that's uh i believe that's unheard
of i mean i'm sure it happened but uh
not in recent times uh but yeah here of
course you resign uh because if you
capture the bishop a it brings a queen
into the game with check of course we
pick up the knight so there's nothing
there and if you avoid this king e7 we
simply pick up the knight and then we
don't have to worry about the check and
then we're just going to promote our
ponto queen
yeah after this beautiful g8 bishop
check uh robson resigned and an
excellent victory for fabiano caruana
who is now back in the tournament which
sounds odd because after losing two
games you shouldn't be able to be back
in the tournament uh but he's only
trailing by one point so uh behind the
leaders linderman wesley so and samuel
savion uh so it's still possible for
fabi to actually win the us chess
championship it's not going to be easy
but there are still four more rounds to
go
and if there will be tie breaks uh maybe
it's even enough for him to uh equalize
with with the leaders uh and then maybe
he can play the tiebreaks so i think
it's still possible for him to win uh
we'll we'll see what happens uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh that's the power of the bishop pair
even when the game is completely equal
for like 50 moves uh the bishop pair
almost always prevails
uh so once again i really hope you guys
enjoyed it i will i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to david sorodi i
hope you had a good one and that you've
spent it with many friends you know
and with joy and chess
and i would like to thank mr hoody guy
tom derelo you'll never walk alone in hb
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it uh as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the usgs championship
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day